as chair of the division three of the
house finance committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of covet 19 pandemic in
accordance with the governor's emergency
order number 12 pursuant to executive
order 2020-04 is extended
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
please note that there is no physical
location to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting which
is authorized pursuant to the governor's
emergency order
however in accordance with the emergency
order i'm confirming that we
are providing public access to the
meeting by telephone and with video
the committee is using zoom video
webinar for this meeting all members of
the committee and the staff estate
agencies with the generations have the
ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through this platform the
public has access to contemporaneously
watch and or listen to the meeting on
zoom or phone
following the directions and links
provided in the house calendar
uh starting at house calendar eight
through
sixteen uh and as previously stated
now the public can have access
telephonically
and those are instruct instructions are
in the house calendar as i pointed out
if people are having trouble hearing
what we're doing then contact the lba
underscore fiscal
leg.state.nh.us
and if we got feedback that the public
is
having trouble accessing this meeting uh
we'll adjourn and reschedule
uh please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call
um representative dean if you get ready
for that
uh let's let's start the meeting by
taking a roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room
with you during this meeting which is
required under the right to know law
and then i would transition to
say that i think this is
absolutely the last issue there are no
more issues
after this if we finish this issue we
are done
is that right mr ripple
that's correct okay is there anyone else
who
who may disagree with the observation
that after we
close out these sysc amendments we are
done
as a division at least for the budget
work
okay all right so that serves as our
would you take the chair seat and um
take us on these five sysc amendments
that mr ripple worked out with ols
i'm here in my home in concord and i'm
alone
representative nordgren i'm here
uh in my dining room in hanover alone
representative rodgers i'm kathryn
rogers i am in concord in my apartment
with my daughter representative era
president home alone in my home office
representative edwards
i'm in my home office in auburn family
in the house
door closed representative weiler
i think he's late i'm representative
bean i'm home in guilford
all set thank you and then with that
uh uh representative wallner if you do
us the honors of uh
finishing our work on sysc
well i think we had a good discussion
yesterday and
um went through all of the proposed
kevin did some work for us last night
got it done really
very quickly and sent us a summary sheet
i think that summary sheet really no
so this was from kevin last night
he sent the summary sheet and all of the
uh final amendments as we worked on them
yesterday
i know some russian
okay so i see representative earth had
it represented edwards had it
oh okay that's great thank you kevin
there it is
so there's the summary sheet kevin sent
us last night
um 9
26 the first one
we adopted that one yesterday with no
changes
so that one has already been adopted by
the division
representative um edward how do you want
to go do you want to
vote on each individual piece or do you
want to just do this at the end
i'll i'll do defer to you uh sitting in
the chair to do it how you think
makes the most sense uh i i would i
would tend at this point to go
um item by item just to make sure that
we've seen it and we can have one vote
at the end if everything looks okay
okay so that's what we'll do so we've
already done
the first one um 9 26 we already
voted on it yesterday the second one is
um the closure there were no changes to
the one that was offered yesterday
um that one sets the date for the
closure
the third one is the study commission um
it isn't it's a new amendment because
there were some
errors in the original and it changed it
from the consumer advocate to the child
advocate which makes a lot more sense i
think
change
i think we pretty much agreed on that
change yesterday
um sorry representative weiler does have
his hand up
hi representative weiler would you like
to take over
oh i'm sorry it's because he's in
attendees and he wants me to bring him
okay so sorry you could you can go on i
think he just wanted to be brought over
as a panelist
okay would he like does he want to take
over
going through this or does he want me to
finish you've got a head start
mary jane keep going i've got the same
papers in front of me so
we'll be all on the same page thank you
okay
um number four and number five
um our amendments that we saw yesterday
that we decided not to
not to offer so those are um not being
offered
uh number six is the transitional cost
we did some amendment to that um we took
out
the word relocation we removed that
from the um but we left in employment
employee training
we moved a 650
000 appropriation um
from what i think it was in um the
original
930 and we moved that to this
particular amendment um
it provides the um
provides the department with two
million and fifty thousand dollars
to um do the work they're going to need
to get ready
for um all the transitional cost of
closing down
um sununu and getting the children
placed in
the appropriate appropriate placements
uh number seven and i think we uh
agreed with that one yesterday number
seven is job training
um this is for the people who work at
sununu
who um hopefully we'll
want to relocate to a job or to take
another job in state service since
they've been with us for a long time and
they're valuable
employees um this would
allow them to get some job training to
move to a different job
i think there there's a there are a lot
of people there who have
great skills that we can we can
certainly use in other parts of state
government
so um and as we saw when we went through
the budget there were
a lot of a lot of job opportunities
available so
hopefully that that will be a smooth
transaction
transition and then finally it was the
disposal of the property
and we did change that one
um we
if you go to that one number eight
we just um shortened it and
turned the property over to
administrative services
and um those are the ones that we went
through
yesterday we i think we had agreement on
them yesterday
is there any anyone who disagrees with
those
with how we um proceeded and with the
amendments
see no i don't see or hear any
disagreement so i would turn it back
over to
uh chairman edwards to take a final vote
on them
okay question
sure sharon um no uh we
we also got a email last night from
maura o'neal um i would hope that we
could
pass this on to the senate so hopefully
she can uh probably
work with them to maybe modify or
whatever
with the thoughts she had they obviously
came in a little late for us
so i assume should be taking those to
um chairman edwards i'm turning it back
over to you to take the official vote
okay uh well thank you um
does anyone want us to have popped open
each of these attachments just to verify
that the summary sheet is accurate or
uh would that just be redundant at this
point is there anyone that wants to
pop open each one to look at it that
would be done just for completeness
i'm not seeing anyone indicating that
they would want to do that
so uh i would entertain a motion
to accept uh the the uh the amendments
as documented in the summary sheet that
we're looking at
to include the deletion of some
amendments that
we do not want to offer is is there a
motion on that so moved i would move uh
we move them all at once so you want to
do them one at a time i
i was prepared to move them all at once
unless you
uh see reason to to do it separately
nope all at once is fine with me
okay so we have a motion
uh is there a second i'll second it
uh not seeing any um mr clerk are you
ready to take a roll
i am thank you sir
all right on the motion to adopt all of
these things as briefed
representative earth yes representative
weiler yes
representative bean yes
representative wallner yes
representative nordgren yes
representative rogers
yes chairman edwards
yes mr chair of the voter 7-0
and i'll list all these amendments here
all right so thank you for that and uh
so i think that concludes the division
three work as we prepare i
am i have one more amendment that uh
i have been working on with with lynn
obrechts and she's
uh closed her thing and i hope we can
come back uh maybe this afternoon
to uh to pass that it's it has to do
with the emergency
thing and what we're trying to do is
find enough votes
to pass the budget and some of the
people have pledged to vote if we can
get this
amendment in so is is there a problem
with
meeting uh later today and bringing that
amendment forward
um i i
represented norton well can you
tell us what the amendment will be
please
i haven't seen all the details but what
it is is is
the state of emergency and it it puts
some of the language that we've heard
about
bringing the legislature into the state
of emergency limiting the number of days
of an emergency
and limiting the number of days that i
saw some
some of it briefly but she's working on
it and doesn't have it finalized yet so
we
we want to have the legislature involved
in the state of emergency basically
um when will we have it to look at
um lynn is working on it right now
and uh working with ols she came up with
the idea last night she had phone calls
with several people
who are going to vote against the budget
we need all the votes we can get
so she tried to find out what would what
would bring them along
and she's got uh pledges from them if if
we do this amendment and we're going to
need every vote
so i'm hopeful we can bring this in so
so uh to your basic question uh
representative weiler
uh i i don't i don't
really have a problem with it i i would
just
hope that we could meet a couple of
boundary conditions
uh one would be that we could see it in
writing
at least you know 30 minutes to an hour
before we
get into discussing it and voting so
so the earlier we can see it the better
i think people need to
to think through the implications a
little bit and that doesn't really
happen for me until i see something
i agree so so if we could do that that
would be great
um and then the other one is i would
just ask
about um protocol is this
is it sufficiently germane to division
three are
there any rules that we can only take on
jermaine
hb2s this is a this is this is me
asking a question because i this is a
little outside of what
uh my experience has been in the last
month
so so if i'll get an answer to that and
then represent an order and come back to
you
thank you representative yes
i thought you called on representative
nordman i was just telling her to stand
by i wanted to get an answer first
yes as soon as i have it in writing and
in an
acceptable form i will see that it gets
emailed to everybody
on this division and give you time to
to look it over and hopefully by what
time is it now
hopefully by one o'clock uh everything
will
okay and is there an issue with
germaness is it sufficiently germain i
don't understand because it's just
outside of
of uh what i would consider dhhs
and veterans home boundaries i just want
to make sure
that we're that there's no issues with
us
voting it out well emergency declaration
is so widespread and i'm sure it applies
representative do you have a question
well
i'm i'm just wondering if we're
bringing in an amendment so maybe mary
jane
and kathy and i will bring in another
amendment i
can think of something we would like to
change in house bill 2
so are we open to other amendments if
we're going to be
so i think that's a good question and
it's a question of fairness
and if you have an alternative amendment
related to
the state of emergency i think we would
certainly
uh consider that and if you have a
a different amendment that's not related
to the state of emergency
i i think i would uh give you an
opportunity to introduce
one thing please um um
that's the islam you know i just would
hope it would be truly
important to you and not um
dylatory in any way and i don't think it
would be but i
need to say it i find it pretty amazing
that we will be
putting in an amendment to get
votes and that that's been publicly
stated
that that's the only reason we're doing
this
because all the other divisions have
finished
i think it's outrageous but whatever if
if we let you put in an amendment would
doing horse trading when it's pretty
obvious that
you're trying to convince your caucus
in any way possible whether or not it's
germaine
or not the public is watching this and i
i'm shocked i'm shocked it's sausage
making
just to respond to that i maybe we're
going to win the uh transparency of the
year award
so there's that possibility as well
um representative waller
um i was wondering why why wouldn't this
have been an amendment that was brought
into the full committee when we do
when we do the budget so that all
divisions
are the entire um finance committee
is involved in this instead of just one
division which
hasn't really talked about this issue in
any of our deliberations i mean we've
we've been here for
i don't know it feels like it feels like
a really long time but i guess it's
really about a month
and we haven't had this before us to
think about
and to really talk about
i just wondered why it wouldn't come to
the full full committee
and have it available to all of us
in more timely manner as chairman of the
full committee i'm bringing it forward
to the only division that's left still
meeting
that hasn't closed its agenda up and
some of the things that i found out at
our caucus
was that i didn't have enough votes and
so i've been negotiating with people to
get enough votes to pass a budget they
don't want to waste the time over all of
us to try to
craft a budget together that we can
agree on in most cases
on a lot of the issues and then have it
defeated and have all our efforts be for
naught
i've gone through this seems like every
time there's a budget
and so i wish these people would come
forward to us i told them all this in in
various caucuses if you want to be in
part of the budget
come to us early come to our meetings
put in your input early
yeah they wait till the last minute then
they come with demands
and unfortunately we've got to try to
meet some of these demands
so that we can pass a budget that's my
most important job as the chairman of
this committee is to get a budget passed
so i have to take some steps to do that
and and uh lenovo and i have been
working with the different caucuses as
has
representative beam he's also been a key
player in this working with these
caucuses
and we're finding out things that we are
having to go back and say okay
so just as we had things come to us like
the sununu youth center said you got to
do this you got to do that
we all agreed on that we all brought
that amendment in we had some good
cooperation
i'm delighted to see that now this one i
have to get cooperation among my own
group
so this is what i'm suggesting i'm
asking for the cooperation of the chair
of division three
and i will make certain that all of you
see the language
for a period of time before we vote
we're asking first to come back at one
o'clock before
the chairman closes out the work of
division three because this is the only
working division now that i can come to
as chairman of the committee
so that's what i'm doing thank you
uh well i i i think
uh we can support your request uh i i
i it does seem to me that dhhs
has been and will be as effective as any
department
in the state government in terms of
reacting and responding to the
pandemic and the in the state of
emergency orders uh and
and i'm glad that we'll be able to see
something before
we uh we have to discuss it i i
um what was it also
oh so i want to give you a foreshadow
because
i've i've been talking to some of these
folks too
and if lynn is working on if
representative ober is working on what i
think she's working on
it's basically something that puts into
effect
the the the effect of a
concurrent joint resolution terminating
the state of emergency i think
i think it's probably very close to that
so you haven't seen it exactly yet but
it it deals in the same area yes sir
okay so um
mr ripple do you have any thoughts for
us because we we
i think we're going to go into recess
and that we're going to receive
a document from representative weiler
sent to the entire committee
prior to coming out of recess and
he said he needs at least till one
o'clock
that's when i'm thinking we would come
back out of recess
do you have any thoughts any protocol
issues any
i just don't want to step on anything
i have no thoughts i think if you want
to go into recess and come back at 1pm
that's
that's just fine all right
so um so uh representative norgren
if if you have um if you have an
amendment
i i i would still uh have us discuss it
i think i think that would be fair to
you you know the essence of what we're
doing you know the essence of why we're
trying to do it
you know so um so there's that
all right well with that uh let's uh
i'll i'll call the meeting of division
three into recess until 1 pm
so if you would put up the sign mr
ripple and cease recording
chairman
it it's it's one o'clock but i'd like to
just wait a few more minutes to give
yes
okay if you could oh now we're recording
thank you miss ripple
um all right so uh it's a
101 and we're coming back out of our
lunch recess
uh the committee has come completed all
work so far
we have uh one last hb2 to consider
mr ripple a few will bring it up and
then
representative weiler is a sponsor do
you want to speak to it
a little big if you could
if we could see lot just lines one
that doesn't uh is that too small for
you representative rogers you've had a
i have a copy of the amendment myself so
i can read it there
okay very good all right uh
representative weiler
all right thank you mr chair this is a
uh
a way for many of the people in the
legislature are upset that we weren't
involved in
at all in the declaration of emergency
and uh wanted to have some say in it and
many people wanted to terminate it uh
what this does is going forward
emergency can only be for 21 days and
then if you want to
continue it after that you have to have
a meeting of the legislature unless half
of us are
disabled or missing for whatever the
emergency was
and uh then we can continue to give you
another 21 days
so basically it's where
we're the policy-making body please get
us involved
if you're going to have a declaration of
emergency and you're going to put rules
in it so
we want to have a hand in it and i think
all of us
that are elected to to have a hand in
new policy
want to be involved in anything that is
is emergency related so this this calls
for us to do that
so um if there are questions uh
i'll uh i'll recognize people for
questions
is there an an effective date on this or
would this be effective upon
um signature if it were to make it
through the process
well um lacking anything else since
we're amending
hp2 with this i guess it would be a
effective date would be when the hp2 is
effective
so um it would affect the current state
of emergency
uh if it were to be signed by the
governor it would
immediately apply to the current state
of emergency or would the
current state of emergency be exempt
my opinion is that if it doesn't have a
different
effective date then it would be
yes i have a series of questions
actually
um which i made let's go ahead and keep
asking them this is we're now in the
conversation mode
okay um the first of all is is
um are you aware representative that the
edna committee
this morning passed a bill that would
make this
redundant and i'm not sure if it is
actually
um at odds with it some places they
passed a bill that
actually my understanding is they had
three or four work sessions on and they
had
a public hearing which this bill did not
um
and their bill um
is quite extensive it calls for um
among other things um the
the legislature to vote um
on various parts of this it calls for
the involvement of the executive council
in in with it not just the governor and
so forth um
i know that you went and spoke to them
as one of the experts they called in
um and i just wondered if you were aware
that they passed a bill this morning
well thank you i was not aware
and does that make it any different the
fact that they passed a bill this
morning
for the need for this um
since there is a bill that's going to be
coming in front of us the same day
or the same three days as the budget
would that change your opinion for the
need of this
well i guess we're going to rely on the
senate to work this all out
and they may take this out in lieu of
keeping the other one which is more
detailed perhaps and
has had more study but for now this is
this is a request and i i acceded to it
and i said i would put it in and i did
thank you because i do know this morning
you said that it was
um in order to have the budget passed
that you needed this in so i didn't know
if
the other bill would would help with
that request um
so i'm going to ask the questions i have
on the the the
actual bulk of this bill um or this
amendment
i first of all i'm curious as far as
what some terms
mean um the terms incapacitated
and missing are not defined here
and i'm curious as to what they mean
that they seem
clear but they could mean quite a number
of things incapacitated for instance
um could mean the person is
incapacitated in that they are
incapacitated and that they have a fear
of catching covet or whatever virus
that so they don't want to leave their
house or does it mean that they're
if this were a real serious emergency
atomic bomb a hurricane that
tore all our wires down or perhaps
injured us and floods and so on
but there was something horrible enough
that
we're not able to get a majority of the
legislators
to a meeting and that this would take
the place
if it's that bad so it's it's
kind of leaves it up you know not
everybody would be incapacitated to the
same extent but if you had
if you're unable in other words the
intent is
can you get a meeting of a majority of
the legislature
and for whatever reason you can't either
they can't get there because the roads
are broken or
open and big gaps in the roads or
their cars don't work because of emp uh
explosion or something like that then
yeah there would be a problem
with it tries to foresee many other
things and
and these these terms are probably
hopefully hopefully taken broadly
like you say incapacitated could take
many forms
okay and so i would assume the same
thing with missing is that
we're leaving to the clerk to define
what those terms are
well in other words we can't contact
that person we've tried eight times
it could be that the phone doesn't work
could be that they're uh
you know living in a tent they can't get
in the house it could
could be a lot of things but in other
words missing as far as
trying to get a group together so it's
kind of very broad interpretations
we tried to get a meeting of the
legislature and
you know 100 didn't answer the phone
100 the town police reported they're
missing
you know and so on like that all right
the next question i have is is regarding
the clerk i was a little alarmed that
the clerk
is the person that's given all the power
in here to make these decisions the
clerk while
um is is elected by the legislature
has no accountability to the the
citizenry of the state
they're elected by the legislature why
did you choose the clerk
instead of the leaders of the two bodies
being the president of the senate
or the speaker of the house which are
elected by at least by their districts
and then by their peers
i'm a little concerned that we're
leaving the the entire power
to make this decision of who's missing
who's incapacitated and so forth
to somebody that's um only accountable
to the legislature not accountable to a
larger group
in the citizenry um i would have been
much more comfortable had it been
um somebody that's elected by at least
some portion of the citizenry
the um the speaker and the majority
leader quite often
are from a pretty good distance from the
capital
but generally the clerk's fairly close
and somebody that is a responsible
person who knows all the numbers
who knows all the names and usually has
access to them
and all the contacts then that person
is likely to be able to get to the
capitol
and perform those duties whereas if your
head like
gene chandler is is two hours away
uh what if what if there was a problem
between where he lives and getting to
concord
um the majority leader could be going in
another direction where
it's difficult to get there this is
let's assume some some
travel uh problems to great to gather
and it also assumes that the clerk is
nearby
and has access to the lists and the
names wouldn't have to dig them out if
he could get to the capitol and the
capital was intact it would have those
records
but the speaker couldn't have them in
his home or
or wherever they the uh people in charge
of the house would
would be on the charges but does it give
you any
um i don't know discomfort in the fact
that it's someone that isn't elected and
is not accountable to the general
population
uh well not in this case there is
they're responsible to the house
and if they're doing something that the
house doesn't like they could be
replaced at any time
first we'd have to have a gathering
right
and then i guess this is just a
communication person to do communication
um and then the other question about
about the
um definition is what would be a nominal
state of emergency in the last
paragraph that's added about a nominal
state of emergency as opposed to a
i don't know a full state of emergency i
guess and i'm curious what a nominal
state of emergency is
it's one it's it's named an emergency
but it's not an obvious thing
like oh for some reason we can't get
money out of a bank is that really an
emergency well
there's people looking for us to spend
it so how do we get
all these creditors are coming here we
can't the banks there's a bank holiday
or whatever
the government has declared at some
moments the only thing that's an
emergency is we can't get at the money
okay what do we do now well we're gonna
have to declare an emergency just to get
the
predators to back off uh because we
can't cash our checks we can't get our
money out of the bank and so on so
it's named an emergency but looking it
has no appearance of an emergency that's
nominal
and then i guess just my last question
again is is
why is it so important as i said the
bill did pass
in the edna committee today which was a
policy committee
after a great deal of study and a great
deal of work why is it such an emergency
to bring this in
in a division in the budget instead of
going through the policy committee
for a policy um instead of putting it in
a budget bill
where it really isn't a monetary bill
i guess there was some fear by those who
wanted to make sure that it was like
belt and suspenders that what if the
what if the committee the edna committee
couldn't agree on something what if it
had language in there that
couldn't pass uh it's like two bytes of
the apple so
all right we'll get it one way or the
other so
and as i said i have to i have to try to
get people to vote for the budget
and uh if this is something that i can
get him to agree to to vote for the
budget then
have any further questions
representative rogers not right at the
moment thank you very much mr chairman
we'll come back to you if you do um so
uh rep representative weiler
uh so i'll go with uh representative
wohlner first should you have your hand
up
there um i just wondered if
representative wyler
could sort of walk through
um the clerk would
you you tell me how it would actually
work i'm having some
i'm having some difficulty following how
this how this works
um the
governor could declare a state of
emergency
the legislatures are available say it's
july august
and we could be called in
but um they didn't do that they just
declared an emergency but now he's got
21 days
so we're all hearing about it we're all
wanting to know what's going to go on we
all want answers we all
want to be able to have some input into
this
and uh and we call up in the
the uh speaker tells puts out the word
to
to heaven have us gather or the
president of the senate
and they they try through the normal
means and they also assign the clerk to
call
and if so speakers put out the word
through the regular channel if it
doesn't work through the regular channel
in this
then the speakers or the clerk's going
to try several other channels
and put his staff to work making all
phone calls and
call towns and see if town is affected
in the emergency that
nobody can get in or out of a particular
town and so
they're going to try to get a a uh a
quorum
assuming that this emergency has kept
people from traveling or kept people
from communicating
there might there might be an inability
to contact some members how many members
you don't know it depends on what part
of the state was
affected and how widespread it was but
assuming it didn't affect
the whole state maybe we could get a
quorum together
discuss what the problems were talk
about how we would
and use the collective of all the
state reps with knowledge of whatever
they're part of the state that's left
what things are available and use more
than just uh
you know the emergency planning and the
governor
to try to help uh away the emergency
and come up with ideas of what to do
just to have more heads in the game than
just a handful so that's that's what the
representative did you have a question
go ahead
representative i did thank you um
so what we're really saying
this removes the power of the highest
elected official in the state the
governor
and it gives the power to the clerk
of the house is that can you
mr representative weiler can you explain
that to me am i
reading this correctly or am i not
reading it
the way it's meant to be the uh
declaration of the emergency would
likely all first come
would have to come first from the
governor i have selected a patient
then in consultation with those other
elected officials
we would gather as appropriate the only
power the clerk has is to discern
whether we can contact everyone or not
and whether we can get an answer from
everyone or not that's his only power
is to see if there is the availability
the alternative methods that would have
been used by the clerks
by the speaker's office are also in
effect so
the clerk is working and so is
leadership working
of both parties to try to find how many
people are
able to travel able to to join and
and then then the clerk is going to add
him up and he's going to say well
we've only been able to contact 150
people or whatever
but that would then return the power to
the governor
if we are unable to gather and act but
if we are unable to gather an
act then we will have consultation with
the governor and
probably the emergency preparedness
person
and get everything explained to us since
we are the
people close closest to the citizens
then we would be able to get back to our
citizens and give them more details
because some of them
if everybody called emergency management
they'd never get through on the phone
but if 350 of us could gather
get a good detailed briefing when we go
back home anybody calls us
we can give them the details of what's
happening what's expected
and where to go and what to find and so
on and we could also help pass on
information
um through our contacts so
the idea is to get more people involved
so that we can all have a hand in this
and also be helping thank you
your hand is still up representing
northern do you have a question
no i think i think i
don't understand how it's being done and
i
think i can't help so thank you
so i i have a few questions
representative wilder if i may
um yes there's a few of them and i would
just like to
use these to try to establish something
like a problem statement because we have
legislation here
that's you know the purpose of which is
to solve a problem and i'd like to just
make sure that
there's a common view of what we think
that problem may be
so um is is it
is isn't it true that in the new
hampshire constitution
the governor's uh powers were
intended to be uh less significant than
the legislatures
which is in part why we have an
executive council
also as a kind of a regulating body
over the governor yes we have one of the
weakest governors of the
states and so isn't it
true that um the current rsas
around state of emergency uh were formed
in the
pretty much in the immediate aftermath
of 9 11.
i think so and then
uh isn't it true that uh this state of
emergency
is the first time since those laws were
enacted
that the state of emergency powers were
uh
used yes
uh and
do you share as i do a belief that
there is a significant amount of the
legislature
uh that that believes that its
legislative
role uh with during this state of
emergency
has been minimized beneath the role
envisioned in the spirit of our
constitution
yes i would and then
after watching the way the state of
emergency has
played out um do you do you share as i
do the
the idea that um there
there does not appear to be any firm
metrics that the public currently
understands
to be the conditions under which the
state of emergency will be lifted
yes and if there are no firm metrics
under which the current state of
emergency could be lifted
isn't it potentially possible under our
current statutes
that the state of emergency would last
in perturbity
it could happen unless there was some
control
so then isn't it true that about the
only check
on the governor's budget under the
current rsas
is whether or not we pass a budget
because if we do not pass a budget
the governor's ability to resource the
operation of the government in an
emergency is limited it's constrained
it's not
stopped but it's constrained it is
constrained yes
so then isn't it reasonable to believe
that since the budget is our only
legislative check on the on the governor
that we use the budget process
as a way of refining and reestablishing
an appropriate balance between the
legislature and the governor
all um those those were my questions
thank you sir
uh representative rogers yes um
so are you saying that a um bill that
passes into statute
is not effective in um in
i haven't the statute that did pass
didn't have a way to end it this one is
is doing that and i believe the one
that's
before ways and means as a way to to
have our
involvement the legislation involved in
ending a state of emergency but i think
under current laws i don't think there
is
um so may i clarify that answer for you
sir
yes i i i do believe under current rsa
there is a way for the legislature to
halt a state of emergency
and that is depend upon uh a
joint concurrent resolution of the house
and the senate
and that gets to be problematic when the
house and the senate are not
in session because uh with ols shut down
there is no administrative method
by which a legislature can initiate a
joint current resolution
particularly when the house rules do not
permit
a legislature a legislator to
directly introduce a bill to the house
without passing through
the ols registration process
i i think that's maybe a more complete
answer sir
yes i agree representative rogers
yes so i guess what i'm asking is the um
the
um house bill that passed edna today
as i spoke to earlier you don't believe
and i guess i would open this to both
mr chair both mr chairmans um
neither of you believe that that bill
would enable the
legislature to do the same thing that
this amendment does
well as i said it's belt and suspenders
either one or the other will pass
and if if the one that passes the house
then goes on to the senate and the
senate has both of these then they will
find one of them redundant
lightly and probably perhaps not
keep them both okay but you did so
but you did say a moment ago um that
that you thought the budget was the only
way to do that and i'm just clearing it
up that
that you do think that we can do it
through statute as well it's this other
one
no our budget is is the main way of
controlling
the other parts of government as the
legislature
because we can stop their funding but
that's that's quite a slow process you
could stop the funding right now and
they could spend whatever they had
already
so but yes the budget is a prime means
of control
and it would appropriate to put this in
the budget but if we can put it in
statutes
for the other one then i'm sure that the
senate will make some adjustments
and probably not keep both of these but
until that happens i
feel like belt and suspenders is a good
way to go
but it might um it you also said this
morning that
right now you didn't have the votes to
pass it so if a budget doesn't pass and
the other bill
does that in fact might be the most
effective way to
to in fact end the state of emergency
i agree thank you
so so uh representative weiler
is it unusual for the house to send two
two or more similar bills to the senate
for the senate
to then accept and determine
prioritization and how they'll manage
them and
uh merge or or or
itl either or both is is this unusual to
have multiple similar bills
it's not all that common but it's not
totally unusual because sometimes
there's
two different committees that have
similar bills and
maybe they're different mechanism for
some reason or other put it in one
committee and not in the other
and they might still pass it might still
have very similar control
systems but um you know and then they
would both go to the senate and the
senate might have their own version
or they might combine them both take
parts of one of parts another i've seen
that out
but you know
it's not unusual for them to have two
paths
to accomplish a mission and quite often
it's senate bills and house bills that
read almost identically
that are passed into both bodies then
the other body decides what to do with
the other version
so we've had that happening
i noticed one hand up from attendees
um two two questions one for the
committee
are there any are there any more
questions
i'm not seeing any right now uh
representative weiler would you
entertain a question from an attendee
it's a
person named jay rogers i don't know who
jay rogers is
yeah i will i will answer your question
the best of my abilities
okay so uh jay rogers if you would uh
please
ask a question uh to the extent that
you're asking a question
that's that's good process to the extent
you you want to um
you know go beyond asking a question i i
think
we're a little bit short of time so if
you if you want to do more than ask a
question i'd
ask you to limit it to three minutes hi
representative edwards this is josh
rogers i'm a reporter i
push my hand up uh in error but i thank
you for your courtesy
i'm gonna mute myself again thank you
josh
are there any other questions from or
are there questions from the attendees
i think we can entertain a limited
number
okay so i'm not i'm not
seeing any uh i would at this point
if there's no further discussion i i
think uh i would entertain a motion
to uh to accept the amendment is uh
presented
uh with the four digits zero one zero
second moved and seconded is there any
uh not seeing any
representative wallner is that a you're
are you getting ready to say something
or
no okay so
go ahead i i don't want to cut you off
if you have a comment and a comment to
make
no i just i'm i'm just concerned about
the process and here we are at the end
um and putting this putting in the
division three recommendations
um i hope that when we get to i hope
when we get to full committee
that we have a a lengthy discussion
about this or
you know that the whole committee the
whole um finance committee talks about
this
being in the budget um it seems like
it's sort of a last-minute
kind of a last-minute thing and um the
other divisions haven't really seen it
so i i hope that chairman weiler will
have a
full full discussion about it when we
get to um
full committee thank you i will
see two more hands on representative
rogers and then representative nordgren
yeah i just have a concern i i do know
that there are bills that go over that
are similar
to the senate it's not unusual however i
think in this case
the bill that that edna passed as i said
had a number of work sessions brought in
a number of experts to speak to the
committee
including representative weiler to speak
about the fiscal
committee and its responsibilities in an
emergency or declaration of emergency
including looking at a number of studies
that talk about
states reactions and how they deal with
federal money they had a number of
safety advisors talk to them
they combined um information and
conversation from four different bills
that had different ways of of dealing
with this and representative mcguire
and her committee spent a great deal of
time trying to figure out how to deal
with this
um in a bipartisan way because you're
right a lot of
people on both sides of the aisle had a
concern about um
the legislature being locked out of this
process over the last
year and a half they put a great deal of
work in it now we see something that's
been put together in a very short period
of time
with a number of terms very loosely
defined giving a great deal of power to
to people that are not elected he could
be busy like that's just the way it goes
and um and so and then we're just thrown
into this
at the last minute and told that it's
because we need to get votes for the
budget
i know we need to get votes for the
budget there's various ways to do it
but i think that that we're playing with
something very loose
and loose and free without a great deal
of thought to it which is not the way
that this committee traditionally has
worked this committee is traditionally
um not delved into a lot of policy and
then when we do delve into policy
it's to quote clean things up it's to do
things with a great deal of thought
um and i think that this is not the way
we do things
so i i just i don't understand why we're
doing this at the last minute why we're
doing it with no thought
and why we're putting out a product
that's not the best product
available um so i'm concerned about it
i've had some thoughts ever since i
testified before
edna i had six years in my air force
reserve career
that i was attached to the federal
emergency management agency
i went through several classes and
several
exercises in those years and
i can tell you one thing that you learn
in emergency management you never know
what's coming
and it's always different every time you
can never plan for everything that's
going to happen you can plan for the
ones that have happened in the past and
you can see your results of what you did
but the next time it's always different
so
you stay loose and you stay flexible and
you have a lot of ideas and a lot of
things in mind and so that's the best we
can do and this is just
an element of it in my mind thank you
so representative norton do you have a
question comment
just a comment thank you mr chair i
would just
um stress my disappointment in this
process
i think chair edwards you've been
on the whole very fair to the minority
in the committee
and i'm just disappointed that this
really
colors the way we all feel at the very
end of the day and i think it's sort of
an embarrassment
to the public that we've conducted it
this way today
so i would just like to say i'm
deeply saddened by the way we've ended
up our
time together on the budget thank you
so um representative weiler to
echo your comments i've i've been fema
trained as well in my army reserve duty
and i've spent
time in tactical operations centers in
the hostile fire zone
and in many regards uh what the
governor's had to deal with is much like
that
it's dealing with the unexpected and
it's uh
mobilizing um resources and people the
best that you can to deal with each
crisis i
so flexibility is is is key in all of
that
uh i i agree with all of that so um
i i don't have much else to
ask you about this other than to
highlight the idea
that this is um
a first step in a process neither the
edna
bill nor uh nor
the hb2 will become law until the
governor
signs it and so uh that is dependent
upon
the the senate's uh action or inaction
and um so representative weiler i i
would just ask you this
if if this were truly important to the
legislature
and it was of chief importance
wouldn't it actually be better to put it
into
a budget then it would be into a statute
because it would be harder for the
governor to veto
the budget if it came to that
yes
so um are there any other questions or
comments
all right not seeing any uh this was
the uh further communication after the
motion was
moved and seconded um and so
i think we're ready to take a roll mr
clerk
representative yes representative weiler
votes yes
representative bean yes representative
walden
no representative nordgren
no representative rogers no
representative edwards yes
all right so uh i believe
that completes all of our budget work
uh to date and the division three has
completed its budget work
we have uh work uh planned
for april 12th um it's not in
uh house calendar 16 i believe it's
going to be in 17
calling us together to um discuss
something
the forensic mental hospital um
so so everybody's been encouraged
to invite you know folks that you think
would
be good participants in that once it
gets into the calendar i intend to
invite the chairs of the public works
committee and the hhs committee
to come sit uh in in a panel with us
to to go over um what what
what we can learn uh that day um are
there any questions or comments about
our next get together as a division
which should be april 12th
uh full committee will is i believe it
got in the schedule for the 30th
of tuesday and we'll be doing uh
all the amendments from all the
committees and we'll be doing
each uh division we'll brief the rest of
the full committee
briefings together for the fifth because
after that with the 30th we'll have
most of a week to try to prepare for
each division
to brief the house on the fifth
and we'll be in some of us will be in
the in the chamber and
most of the other people will be on
electronic communications
and then on so we'll have done that two
days before we meet on the seventh
and it's live will be early on the
seventh that we vote for the budget
so everybody should have those dates
down
i believe they'll be in the calendar
and uh we've got a lot done in this
division and
we did i hope bring a lot more
efficiency to hhs
so they won't have to keep struggling to
find people that don't seem to be there
thank you thank you representative
weiler and i'll just uh i'll just say
you know
i was new to finance and and hadn't had
an opportunity to work closely with
any of you uh i hadn't met mr ripple and
i just really appreciate
the willingness of people to reach out
and uh help me
learn both finance and and how to be a
chair uh
all at the same time so i i do
appreciate that i know that i've made
some mistakes along the way
uh representative rogers i i do owe you
an apology
uh for the other day that didn't go the
i was taken a little off guard but
that's no excuse
so um i guess with that
i would just say there it is
you